[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Sievers guten
Abend Ihnen allen für die Polizei hat
ein Einsatz begonnen heute früh der sie
wohl noch länger beschäftigen wird ein
Weiler mit sieben Häusern in Rheinland
soll der Braunkohle weichen gleichzeitig
wird NRW dafür den Ausstieg aus der
Kohle um Jahre vorziehen die Aktivisten
die das Dorf besetzt halten wollen dass
die Kohle da bleibt wo sie ist sie
fühlen sich und den Klimaschutz verraten
auch und gerade von der grünen
Regierungspartei ich spreche dazu
nachher mit dem grünen Vizekanzler
lützerath der Name einer Ansammlung von
Häusern in denen kein lutzerather mehr
wohnt ist längst zum Symbol geworden für
beide Seiten Peter Böhmer guckt auf die
aktuelle Lage vor Ort wo der Polizei
eine komplizierte Gratwanderung gelingen
muss
ein langer Bauzaun um den kleinen Weiler
lützerath der Energiekonzern RWE hat ihn
aufgestellt und bewacht ihn nun höchst
aufmerksam lützerath sagt rWE ist jetzt
geschlossenes Betriebsgelände niemand
soll er reinkommen und die Räumung durch
die Polizei verzögern können es ist
gelungen die Arbeiten von RWE bei dem
Aufbau des Zaunes um lützerat
abzusichern diese Arbeiten sind
abgeschlossen die Kräfte hier in der
Ortslage den ist es gelungen die
Bewegungsfreiheit von BesetzerInnen
Besetzer sehr zu begrenzen wir haben mit
der Räumung erster Hallen begonnen als
insofern ein erfolgreicher Tag am
Vormittag war es allerdings heftig
zugegangen als die Polizei und kurz vor
9 in Richtung der besetzten Häuser
vorrückte
wurde sie plötzlich mit Feuerwerk
beschossen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das ist das was man erwartet und
trotzdem erschreckt ist ein erstmal weil
man die Bilder ja auch nicht mag und es
war ja heute morgen also wir waren die
Polizei war gerade da da ging schon los
mich hat überrascht die Spontanität und
auch die Menge und der Intensität und
die Vielfalt da ist ja nichts
ausgelassen worden
barrikadenbranden laut Polizei sollen
auch Molotow-Cocktails geworfen worden
sein die Aktivisten hatten Lager mit
massiven Pflastersteinen angelegt die
aber offenbar nicht eingesetzt wurden
die meisten der etwa 350 Aktivisten
versuchten allerdings gewaltfrei die
Räume zu verzögern etwa durch
Sitzblockaden
während die Polizei räumte schaffte RWE
Tatsachen der Zaun wurde aufgestellt und
ein Trupp vom Werkschutz baute das
Ortsschild ab ein symbolhaftes Ende des
Örtchens das ohnehin schon lange von den
früheren Einwohnern verlassen worden war
für die besetzenden klimaaktivisten geht
es aber nicht um die zwei Höfe und fünf
Häuser
werden soll diese diese Kohle die die
1,5 Grad Grenze einfach massiv
überschreitet und das hier weiter
abgebaggert wird dann werden wir das ist
Pariser Abkommen nicht einhalten dann
wird die klimawiese viel stärker werden
das wird gerne wirklich weiter erwärmen
das nun ausgerechnet die Grünen in bunt
und Land den Kompromiss mit RWE
mittragen lutzerat Weg die Braunkohle
darunter Abbaggern und verfeuern dafür
fünf andere Braunkohle Dörfer erhalten
und Kohleausstieg auf 20 30 vorziehen
das stößt bei den klimaaktivisten auf
scharfe Kritik und gerade auch bei der
Grünen Jugend ich glaube was wir gerade
sehen ist das bezogen auf die Klimafrage
die Grünen nicht die Antworten liefern
die wir gerade brauchen nicht die
Politik machen die uns hinführt zum 1,5°
ziehen
da droht auch noch politisches ungemacht
während die Polizei am Abend weiter
räumte
guck mal kurz zu Jana Becker live in
lützerath hallo Jana sehr zufrieden sei
die Polizei sagt sie heute wie ist denn
die Situation wie weit ist die Polizei
mit der Räumung gekommen
die Polizei ist heute tatsächlich
weitergekommen als sie im Vorfeld
gedacht hatte wir stehen jetzt hier
gerade auf dem Platz wo am Abend noch
die letzten Lagerhallen geräumt worden
sind die letzten Aktivistinnen und
Aktivisten die sich auf den Dächern
befinden die werden gerade runtergeholt
und direkt neben uns ist nur das Protest
Camp in dem noch vereinzelte
Aktivistinnen und Aktivisten ausharren
und in den Häusern in den umliegenden
Häusern sollen sich auch noch welche
befinden aber das wird jetzt nach und
nach vonstatten gehen insgesamt war der
Tag heute relativ entspannt man hat ja
genug Zeit sich auf den heutigen Tag
vorzubereiten von beiden Seiten aus das
ist nun jetzt ähm ja so friedlich
geblieben ist hat die Polizei
tatsächlich überrascht im Endeffekt
ziehen Sie eine positive Bilanz auch RWE
rückte jetzt heute schon mit ja den den
Baggern an man kann tatsächlich sagen ja
hier werden sehr viele
Politik geschrieben die die einzelnen
Bagger hier teilweise schon die Straßen
jetzt aufgerissen haben waren heute auch
mit am Start am Wochenende soll es ja
noch eine Großdemonstration geben zu der
auch Greta Thunberg erwartet wird also
der Protest geht auf jeden Fall weiter
wenn dann doch in anderer Form jetzt ja
herzlichen Dank nach münsterrad
wir Journalisten bemühen uns sie über
all die Probleme und Herausforderungen
auf dem Laufenden zu halten denen sich
diese Welt stellen muss das ist ja auch
unsere Aufgabe wir warnen deutlich
weniger gründlich sind wir wenn es darum
geht auch immer die Entwarnung zu
liefern die Lage am Gasmarkt und dazu
das Wörtchen entspannt monatelang war
das undenkbar jetzt ist es Realität
monatelang war gasmangel ein
furchteinflößendes Schlagwort jetzt ist
das Gegenteil der Fall die Speicher sind
voll wie praktisch nie zuvor in dieser
Jahreszeit und die Preise sind aktuell
wieder da wo sie vor dem Krieg mal war
waren ist also Zeit für Entwarnung
berichten
es sieht gerade gut aus bei Deutschlands
gasvorräten derzeit sind knapp 91% der
Gasspeicher gefüllt laut
Bundesnetzagentur wurde 2022 in
Deutschland rund 17 Prozent weniger
gasverbraucht als im Vorjahr zudem habe
auch geholfen dass Deutschland ein
Drittel weniger Gas an Nachbarn
weitergeleitet und konstant
Gaslieferungen aus dem europäischen
Ausland erhalten habe Krise beendet oder
ich bin schon eine ganze Ecke
entspannter als vor wenigen Monaten noch
aber gewissermaßen die strukturelle
Gaskrise die uns sicherlich für Jahre
begleiten wird dauert noch an eine Krise
die den Gaspreis immens in die Höhe
getrieben hatte jetzt sind wir auf dem
gleichen Niveau wie vor einem Jahr etwa
14 Cent pro Kilowattstunde Gründe für
den Rückgang das ist einfach der warme
Winter es ist ja nicht nur hier im
Moment warm es ist seit Wochen warm und
es ist ein ganz Europa warm so dass
überall weniger Gas verbraucht wird und
ein weiterer wichtiger Grund ist dass in
ganz Europa Unternehmen und private
Menschen zu Hause ganz massiv Gas
gespart haben und es auch weiter tun das
Einsparen von Energie bleibt weiterhin
entscheidend drei Risikofaktoren könnten
nach wie vor zu Preisschwankungen führen
Angriffe wie auf Nord Stream zeigen die
gasinfrastruktur ist verletzlich der
nächste Winter könnte härter werden als
dieser und Deutschland ist auf flüssig
Erdgas also lngas angewiesen
internationale Preisschwankungen würden
sich auch auf uns auswirken obwohl die
Preise sinken erhöhen sich aber bei
vielen Vertragskunden die Gasrechnungen
das klingt nach Widerspruch der Gaspreis
steigt tatsächlich jetzt in bestehenden
Verträgen die Versorger haben jetzt
gerade zum Jahresbeginn noch einmal
stark erhöht dass die daran dass sich
dabei um Altverträge handelt die noch
mit einem sehr niedrigen Gaspreis
gelaufen sind bei Neukunden kommt der
niedrigere Gaspreis bereits an doch wann
können alle mit besseren Preisen rechnen
jetzt erstmal
ergeben die Versager die höheren Preise
noch an die Verbraucher weiter das kann
auch in den nächsten Monaten so bleiben
ich hoffe aber dass das sich spätestens
zum Jahresende ändern wird auch die
staatlichen Hilfen werden in den
kommenden Monaten den Verbraucher
entlasten die akute Krise scheint also
erstmal vorbei
Robert Habeck ist Vizekanzler
Wirtschaftsminister klimaminister er war
in den vergangenen Monaten auch das
Gesicht der Energie sorgen dieses Landes
jetzt würde ich mal sagen deutlich
sorgen freier Herr habe und Abend guten
Abend Grüße wenn die Gaspreise jetzt
wieder auf dem Vorkriegsstand sind wann
erwarten sie denn dass das bei uns allen
auch tatsächlich im Portemonnaie ankommt
die Gaspreise die wir alle bezahlen
müssen setzen sich immer über einen
längeren einkaufszeitraum zusammen das
heißt noch sind die Preise die bei uns
ankommen durch die Preise des letzten
Jahres sehr hoch das kann sich dann aber
wirklich es kann sich dann aber über das
nächste Jahr wieder abschleifen das
hängt natürlich jetzt von verschiedenen
Voraussetzungen ab und vielleicht bin
ich damit bei dem Punkt wir haben die
Krise beherrschbar gemacht das ist eine
große gemeinschaftliche Leistung dieses
Landes aber die Krise ist noch nicht
vorbei wir sind nur weit besser davor
als wir es befürchten mussten Ende des
Sommers aber wir sind noch lange noch
nicht durch bleiben
Kreisen ist denn dann noch Raum für
multimilliardenschwere Gas und
Strompreis Bremsen des Staates mit
unseren Steuergeldern nun die werden
wenn die Preise so bleiben sowohl bei
der Abschöpfung also Gewinne die wir
abziehen wie auch bei dem was wir
ausgleichen müssen geringer ausfallen
aber es ist ja wie sie eben gerade
gesagt haben dennoch so dass die
Verbraucherinnen und Verbraucher die
Preise die im letzten Jahr aufgelaufen
sind zum Teil mitbezahlen müssen also
neu Verträge können im Moment um oder
unter der definierten Höhe der
gaspreisbremse geschlossen werden aber
diejenigen die in Verträgen stehen haben
die Preiserhöhungen noch zu tragen
deswegen haben die Bremsen sehr wohl
noch ihre Richtigkeit und ihre Bedeutung
nur wird vielleicht das Volumen etwas
geringer ausfallen dass wir ja gut wenn
zu werden das wäre gut wenn es so wäre
Entspannung hört man plötzlich wieder
als Adjektiv
als Substantiv bei dem Thema Entspannung
die ganze Situation man könnte
vielleicht ein bisschen salopp auch
sagen das große Problem ist nicht mehr
dass es zu kalt ist bei uns sondern dass
es zu heiß wird und damit sind wir bei
möglichen neuen Spielraum für die
Politik und damit auch beim Thema
nutzerrat das ja aktuell die Grünen
zerreißt kann man sagen die Zeit für
Kompromisse ist vorbei hat gestern hier
bei uns im heute schon mal ein
Klimaforscher gesagt heißt das denn für
sie man könnte ja auch jetzt angesichts
der neuen Situation nutzerer doch noch
mal neu verhandeln ich will dem Kollegen
nicht zu nahe treten aber wir haben
gerade über die Krise gesprochen die wir
eingedämmt haben aber die noch nicht
vorbei ist wir haben diese Krise
beherrschbar gemacht weil viele Menschen
und die Unternehmen Gas eingespart haben
und wir den Gasverbrauch aus dem
Stromsektor rausgedrängt haben mit und
das ist nicht so richtig stolz bin mit
zusätzlicher braun Kohle Verstromung
davon
Kompromisslosigkeit zu reden verkennt
die Wirklichkeit sind ja noch immer zwei
Krisen da und wir haben im letzten Jahr
tatsächlich eine gefährlich eine
brandgefährliche realistische Gefahr
gehabt dass Deutschland kalt bleibt im
Winter und deswegen sind viele Studien
die vor dem Ukraine Krieg erstellt
wurden als wir noch nicht zusätzliche
Mengen braunkohlestrom an die an den
Markt bringen mussten nicht auf das Jahr
23 und fortfolgende zu beziehen die sind
einfach falsch und wir sind im Moment in
einem Modus wo wir zwei Krisen
kompromisshaft zusammenbringen können
aber das heißt da habe ich diese großen
Anstrengungen da jetzt Energie zu
besorgen auch wenn die unter
klima-gesichtspunkten schädlich ist
diese Anstrengungen müssen weitergehen
sie müssen dann hinten raus eingefangen
werden und deswegen ist das was gerade
mit dem Begriff oder mit dem Ortsnamen
lützerat diskutiert wird aus meiner
Sicht nicht richtig
lützerath ist nicht das weiter so der
Energiepolitik der Vergangenheit
Verstromung von Braunkohle es ist nicht
wie überhaupt wird das ewige weiter so
es ist der Schlussstrich da unter wir
mussten leider in diesem Jahr
zusätzliche Mengen Braunkohle die
eigentlich abgeschaltet werden sollten
in den Markt reinlassen um die
gasmangelage zu verhindern aber hinten
raus haben wir den die Verstromung von
Braun Kohle von 38 auf 30 vorgezogen
leider konnten wir das Dorf lutzerat das
ja schon abgebaggert werden sollte dass
RWE gehört dass leer gezogen ist das in
Wahrheit gar kein Dorf mehr ist sondern
leere Hüfte nicht mehr retten aber es
ist das Ende der braunen Kohle
verstromungen NRW es ist nicht das
weiter so und insofern mit großem
Respekt vor der Bewegung ist meiner
Ansicht nach der Ort das falsche Symbol
aber Herr Habeck lützerath ist eben ein
Symbol sie haben es ja gerade selbst
gesagt dass weit über dieses Dorf dieses
winzig kleine Dorf hinausgeht und die
Grünen verlieren da gerade enorm an
Vertrauen und dann Glaubwürdigkeit bei
klassisch grünen WLAN da protestiert ja
im Grunde genommen ihre eigene Wähler
Klientel gegen ihre Politik ja das ist
so das tut auch weh und das ist auch
nicht gut oder
nichts was mich
also es fasst mich auch an oder treibt
mich um so wie alle in meiner Partei
aber trotzdem müssen wir das erklären
was richtig ist und richtig wahr leider
die gasmangelage eine Energie Notlage in
Deutschland abzuwehren auch durch
zusätzliche verströmung von Braunkohle
und hinten raus den Kohleausstieg
vorzuziehen und die Argumentation die
ich jetzt aus Teilen der Klima Bewegung
höre definierte Enddaten Kohle Aufstieg
2030 brauchen wir gar nicht der Markt
regelt das alles die Stromverbräuche
gehen von alleine zurück oder die
Zertifikate der Zertifikate handelt
sorgt dafür dass es unattraktiv wird ist
eine erstaunliche Argumentation denn sie
würde ja eins zu eins übersetzt bedeuten
dass wir gar nicht mehr über Daten von
Kohleausstieg reden müssen insofern nein
ich finde den Protest wie er aufgesetzt
wird nicht richtig an dieser Stelle wir
setzen den Kohleausstieg 8 Jahre früher
im Westen um und ich nehme an die
Bewegung die jetzt in der diskutiert
wird von mir erwarten dass ich ähnliches
auch im Osten Versuche und nicht sage na
ja Daten brauchen wir nicht das regelt
einfach der Markt aber weg vielen Dank
für das Gespräch danke Ihnen
und das Gespräch haben wir aus Termin
Gründen vor einer halben Stunde
aufgezeichnet so Hannah du hast jetzt
weitere Nachrichten in der Übersicht
darunter eine die heute Flug Passagiere
aufgeschreckt hat in den USA und zwar
von Hawaii bis nach Washington DC
tausende Flüge wurden gestrichen oder
sind verspätet Grund für das Chaos an
den amerikanischen Flughäfen war eine
großflächige Störung in einem
Kommunikationssystem das unter anderem
Pilotinnen und Piloten mit wichtigen
Sicherheitsinformationen versorgt
mehrere Stunden durften wegen der Panne
keine inlandsflieger mehr abheben
inzwischen ist das Startverbot der
Flugaufsichtsbehörde aber wieder
aufgehoben worden die Ursache für die
Störung ist aktuell noch unklar Hinweise
auf einen Cyberangriff gibt es laut US
Regierung nicht
die Integrationsbeauftragte der
Bundesregierung aller Bali Rado waren
will Opfer von Rassismus besser schützen
Rassismus sei kein Randphänomen sondern
ein zentrales gesellschaftliches Problem
erklärte sie bei der Vorstellung des
ersten Lageberichts zu dem Thema demnach
haben 22% der Menschen hierzulande
bereits selbst Rassismus erfahren um dem
entgegen zu wirken soll es mehr
unabhängige Beschwerde und
Beratungsstellen geben geplant ist
außerdem
Opfer Initiativen zu stärken und ein
Expertenrat soll definieren wo Rassismus
beginnt
mit Blick auf die massiven Angriffe auf
Einsatzkräfte in der Silvesternacht hat
in Berlin ein Gipfel gegen Jugendgewalt
stattgefunden Berlins Regierende
Bürgermeisterin Giffey kündigte an einen
mehrstelligen Millionenbetrag in die
Sozialarbeit investieren zu wollen
außerdem solle die Strafverfolgung
künftig konsequenter umgesetzt werden
bis zu einem weiteren Treffen am 22
Februar sein konkrete Konzepte zu
erwarten
beim Bundesamt für Migration und
Flüchtlinge wurden im vergangenen Jahr
wieder deutlich mehr Asylanträge
gestellt und
244.000 das ist ein Zuwachs von fast 28
Prozent im Vergleich zum Jahr 2021 die
meisten Anträge kamen aus Syrien
Afghanistan und der Türkei mehr als eine
Million geflüchteten aus der Ukraine die
in Deutschland registriert sind mussten
dagegen keinen Asylantrag stellen sie
erhielten wie in der gesamten EU einen
unmittelbaren vorübergehenden Schutz
der Präsident des Robert Koch-Instituts
Lothar Wieler hat seinen Rückzug
angekündigt zum ersten April wolle er
sich neuen Aufgaben in Forschung und
Lehre widmen der 61-Jährige Stand seit
2015 an der Spitze des RKI und wurde
während der corona-pandemie zu einem der
wichtigsten Ratgeber für die Politik der
jetzige Schritt Erfolge im Einvernehmen
mit Gesundheitsminister Lauterbach für
eine Übergangszeit soll er ki-vize Lars
schade die Führung des Instituts
übernehmen
600 es ist ein Signal an die Ukraine das
heute vom polnischen Präsidenten kommt
es ist auch ein Signal Richtung
Deutschland für die einen soll es
Entlastung bringen für die anderen den
Druck erhöhen polen will der Ukraine
Kampfpanzer liefern vom deutschen Typ
Leopard die Entscheidung sei gefallen
so ganz stimmt das nicht denn Polen
braucht dafür das okay aus Berlin weil
die Leopard 2 in Deutschland entwickelt
wurden und nicht ohne Genehmigung an die
Ukraine abgegeben werden dürfen und das
okay aus Berlin ist nicht da
möglicherweise noch nicht denn der Druck
auf den Kanzler und seine Regierung
steigt auch weil die ukrainische Armee
rund um die heftig umkämpfte statt
bachmut zunehmend in Schwierigkeiten
kommt Dominik lässt Meister hat mehr
Haus um Haus Straße um Straße der Kampf
um die ostukrainische Stadt Solidar
diese Bilder sollen die russische
Söldnertruppe Wagner zeigen die
behauptet die Stadt in der Region Donezk
eingenommen zu haben dieses Foto zeigt
wohl ihren Chef jefgeni prigoschin in
einer Salzmine in Solidar überprüfen
lässt sich das nicht die Ukraine
widerspricht den Behauptungen von
russischer Seite Solidar sei gefallen
die Stadt steht nicht unter Kontrolle
der Russischen Föderation die Kämpfe
gehen weiter
die ukrainische Seite spricht von den
blutigsten kämpfen seit Beginn der
russischen Invasion auch in bachmut 15
km entfernt
die verbliebenen Menschen in der ehemals
74.000 Einwohner zählenden Stadt
versuchen zu überleben sie suchen Schutz
in Kellern versorgen sich notdürftig aus
Angst vor Angriffen traut sich kaum
jemand auf die Straße leben im
Luftschutzkeller
ich habe alle meine Verwandten aus der
Stadt geschickt ich bleibe hier um die
Dinge im Auge zu behalten
zuletzt erzielten moskauz Truppen im
Raum bachmut Geländegewinne das Gebiet
ist von strategischer Bedeutung einer
Einnahme wäre aus russischer Sicht ein
wichtiger Schritt sagen Experten zum
einen weil es ein Verkehrsknotenpunkt
ist also wichtig für russische Logistik
dann für die folgenden Kämpfe und zum
zweiten aber auch wenn man die Kontrolle
überwacht Mut hat könnte man ich sage
bewusst könnte man in den Westen
vorstoßen zum Beispiel auf Klammer
torske und das sind darin liegt die
Bedeutung von Mahmut die Ukraine
militärisch unter Druck Präsident
selenski fordert seit langem westliche
Kampfpanzer treffen heute mit den
Präsidenten von Litauen und Polen in
Lemberg bei dem Polens Präsident die
Initiative ergreift
eine Kompanie von Leopard Panzern wird
im Rahmen einer Koalition Verbündeter
Staaten übergeben Sie wissen aber dass
es eine Reihe von formalen Anforderungen
und Genehmigungen zu erfüllen gilt
für eine Lieferung von Leopard Panzern
braucht es eine Genehmigung von
Deutschland als Herstellerland Polen
jedenfalls ist bereits zu liefern du da
steht fest denn der Seite selenskis und
Deutschland Gerät wieder mal unter
Zugzwang
[Musik]
unser nächstes Thema wird das Klagen aus
der Wirtschaft hört der muss sich beim
Blick auf die Kurse an der Börse ganz
schön die Augen reiben Hannah dem gehst
du jetzt nach die Börsenkurse steigen
und steigen seit Jahresbeginn die
Stimmung könnte also kaum besser sein
ganz anderes Bild dagegen bei vielen
Unternehmen die Klagen etwa über
drohende Produktionsrückgänge Frank
beetmann diese beiden Gegensätze wie
passen die zusammen in vielen Betrieben
ist die Sorge nach wie vor groß wird
alles noch teurer wie verhalten sich die
Kunden der deutsche Maschinenbau
beispielsweise hat im November deutlich
weniger Aufträge bekommen noch ist die
Auftrags Pipeline gut gefüllt aber das
muss nicht so bleiben zudem ist die
Anzahl der Firmen bleibt in Deutschland
gestiegen auch daran merkt man dass sich
die Wirtschaft in einer sehr kritischen
Phase befindet ja der Börse sind sie
sehr viel zuversichtlicher der Dax seit
Jahresanfang über 7% im Plus hier glaube
man dass die größte Gefahren Sachen
Inflation bereits hinter uns liegt und
verweist Beispiel teilweise auf die
wiedergesunkenen Gaspreise besonders
kräftig mit Zuwächsen von 10% und mehr
haben im übrigen die Aktien der
Autobauer in diesem noch jungen Jahr
zulegen können ja und ausgerechnet die
Autobauer blicken skeptisch ins Jahr und
fordern jetzt weitere Unterstützung vom
Staat ja das ist so klappern gehört
natürlich zum Handwerk allerdings sollte
man die realen Gefahren auch nicht
unterschätzen beispielsweise die große
Abhängigkeit von Rohstoffen derzeit
hätten laut VDA 3 von 4 Autoherstellern
Probleme notwendige Rohstoffe zu
beschaffen daher sagt der Verband man
müsste die Bezugsquellen solche
Rohstoffe künftig absichern sonst könnte
das der Branche früher oder später das
Wasser abgraben daher heute die
Forderung nach einer europäischen
Agentur für Rohstoffe die eben genau das
als Aufgabe haben soll vielen Dank für
deine Einschätzung
in den 80er und 90er Jahren gehörte
Tatjana partitz zu den gefragtesten
Topmodels der Welt nun ist die gebürtige
Hamburgerin im Alter von 56 Jahren in
ihrer Wahlheimat Kalifornien gestorben
pates zierte zahlreiche Cover von
bekannten Modemagazinen legendär dabei
dieses Foto unter anderem mit Naomi
Campbell und Cindy Crawford Partys wuchs
in Schweden auf und zog später nach
Kalifornien wo sie auch als
Schauspielerin arbeitete
der Historiker und ehemalige Berliner
Wissenschaftssenator Christoph Stölzel
ist im Alter von 78 Jahren gestorben
zuletzt als Präsident der Hochschule für
Musik Franz list in Weimar begleiterte
Stölzel zahlreiche Ämter in
Kulturpolitik und Medien die erste
Direktor des Deutschen Historischen
Museums in Berlin wurde zum Wegbereiter
für neue museumskonzepte so etwa für das
geplante exilmuseum außerdem war er
kurze Zeit stellvertretender
Chefredakteur der Zeitung die Welt
mangelnde Diversität und Bestechung so
lauteten im vergangenen Jahr die
Vorwürfe gegen die Golden Globes nun
wurde der Filmpreis wieder verliehen mit
neustrukturierter Jury und einem
hollywood-gesicht dass sich gleich
mehrfach freuen durfte
Steven Spielbergs Film The Fable mans
wurde als bestes Drama ausgezeichnet
außerdem erhielt er den Regie glaub
beste Darstellerin in einer Komödie
wurde Michelle jo bester Darsteller in
dieser Kategorie Colin Farrell
zu den Lottozahlen an diesem Mittwoch
die lauten 17 21 24 25 32 48 Superzahl 5
alle Angaben wie immer ohne Gewähr
weiße Häuschen türkisfarbenes Meer
pittoreske Gassen Traumstrände das ist
Griechenland aus dem Bilderbuch aus dem
Urlaubskatalog und das tolle an
Griechenland ist es gibt wirklich viele
Orte dort an denen es exakt so aussieht
die europäische Kulturhauptstadt 2023
ist ganz anders wenn es jemand schafft
LFC nahezu ändern dann kann er die ganze
Welt ändern sagen sie in LFC na 20 km
westlich von Athen zwischen Industrie
brachen und schiffsfriedhöfen und es
klingt schon auch ein bisschen stolz wie
Timisoara in Rumänien dass wir ihn
gestern gezeigt haben will auch die
weitere neue Kulturhauptstadt Europas
alte Schiffsriesen ausrangiert zu
Dutzenden der Schiffsfriedhof von LF
sina ist ein Mann mal des
wirtschaftlichen Niedergangs und einer
der magischen Orte den mimikael
mamarinos zeigt den der Regisseur und
künstlerische Leiter als Bühne nutzen
will
[Musik]
wir beleuchten diese Stelle indem wir
Kunst darauf installieren und das wird
die Aufmerksamkeit hierher lenken so
bringen wir dieses ganze Gelände das ja
eigentlich versteckt und verlassen ist
ans Tageslicht
LF sina ist eine Stadt mit zwei
Gesichtern in der Antike der heilige Ort
eloises der Mysterien weirieden über die
Stillschweigen herrschte und dem Mythos
um Demeter der Fruchtbarkeitsgöttin um
Leben und Tod
in der Neuzeit wird LF Sina geprägt von
Industrialisierung umgezeichnet von
deren Niedergang Mikael Mama Rhinos will
diese Geheimnisse des Wandels aufzeigen
Kultur soll nun verwandeln verfallende
Fabrikgebäude werden für Theater und
Kunst umgebaut
als Kulturhauptstadt 2023 haben werden
sind von dem Besonderheiten von LF Sina
inspiriert worden und das ist was
schönes
die Athener Künstlerin stefanias trutza
ist Bildhauerin in ihren Werken
verarbeitet sie was sie am künftigen
Ausstellungsort vorfindet für die
Kulturhauptstadt LF Sina will sie eines
Skulptur Installation kreieren
inspiriert von den dortigen Eindrücken
und Materialien
gibt es viel Material das mit Baustellen
zu tun hat das habt Ihr bestimmt gesehen
diese großen Mengen an der Küste ich
glaube ich werde diese Materialien wie
hier mit goldblättern
Gold sei stets mit den griechischen
Mythen verbunden und passe daher zu LF
Sina das zu dem ähnlich wie Gold er
entdeckt werden will als offen schön zu
sein
Gold ist etwas dass du zu Tage fördern
musst wie einen archäologischen Fund
also solche Werte die im Boden versteckt
sind
ich denke die Arbeiten werden mit diesem
Spiel des Entdeckens zu tun haben
ein ganz besonderer Ort des LF Sina in
dem nicht Schönheit zählen wird sondern
die kulturelle Spurensuche elf Sina soll
wieder aufblühen als europäische
Kulturhauptstadt 2023
und die bisher kleinste Kulturhauptstadt
und gleichzeitig die älteste
so von 0 Kurve zu Fulko wird gleich nach
uns berichtet das auslandsjournal über
Chinas Radikale corona-wende und gegen
0:30 Uhr mit sich dann Nazan gökte mir
mit unserem heute journal Update von uns
allen hier auch hinter den Kameras einen
angenehmer Abend tschüss
[Musik]
guten Abend seit Tagen ändert sich beim
Wetter wenig auch morgen dreht sich hier
über dem östlichen Mittelmeer ein
kräftiges Tief bringt dort Unwetter
anders sieht das über dem Atlantik aus
denn da ziehen doch in lockerer Folge
die Tiefs schnell über uns hinweg
bringen viel Regen und viel Wind mit
dieses erste kleine tief das liegt schon
heute Nacht über der Nordsee und zieht
im Laufe der Nacht weiter zur Ostsee
wird abgelöst durch das nächste Tief das
erreicht uns dann bis morgen früh und zu
regnet es dann kräftig hier zwischen
Schleswig-Holstein und dem Saarland am
ehesten trocken wird die Nacht zwischen
Berlin Brandenburg und dem Oberheim und
die Temperaturen dazu singen auf 8 bis 0
Grad das auch die Nächte so mild sind
liegt natürlich am Wind und der wird
richtig kräftig Wehen nicht über dem
Ärmelkanal über der Nordsee und der
Ostsee sondern auch im Binnenland werden
wir das merken und so sieht morgen über
Tag das nächste Tief hier über die
Ostsee ab wird abgelöst bis zum Abend
von einem nächsten tief das dann
Schleswig-Holstein erreicht
gefällt also viel Regen so viel Regen
das kleinere Bäche und Flüsse in
Nordrhein-Westfalen im nördlichen Hessen
oder auch in Rheinland-Pfalz über die
Ufer treten können auf dem Brocken im
Harz kann es mal für eine orkanbehör
Reichen und die Sonne werden wir kaum zu
Gesicht bekommen bei Höchsttemperaturen
zwischen 7 und 13 Grad und wechselhaft
geht es noch weiter mit Gewitter am
Freitag mit mehr Sonne am Samstag und am
Sonntag wird es etwas kälter bis bald